bonsoir aurélie des ligues merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
est ce que vous comprenez justement ces
marques qui veulent en finir avec ces
images du passé et qui ont décidé
d'évoluer dans leur dans l'eure dans
leur image alors tout à fait moi ça me
paraît essentielle j'aurais même envie
de vous poser la question de se dire
mais pourquoi est-ce qu'elles ne l'ont
pas fait avant une marque c'est une
personne morale d'une mare une personne
morale qui a un rôle à jouer dans la
société qui leur fait cette société là
aujourd'hui
les lignes bougent les limites bouge ça
fait quand même plusieurs années il faut
réaliser que il y a plusieurs
associations de consommateurs qui
demandent à semmar que la d'arrêter
d'utiliser ces symboles ségrégationniste
qui rappelle un passé qui aujourd'hui
est complètement hors hors de vue les
marques aujourd'hui réagissent plutôt
elle serait peut être pratique mais
elles réagissent mais il paraît
essentiel pour moi de d'être à l'image
de la société de porter les valeurs de
la société dans laquelle on vit
et là on ne parle même plus d'une image
puisque c'est le nom qu'il va falloir
changer en l'occurrence pour cette
marque de riz bien connu ça qu'est ce
que ça implique économiques n'ont en
tout cas pour pour cette marque
alors ça c'est un impact majeur quand on
sait le poids et les investissements
qu'il faut pour faire retenir le nom
d'une marque
l'imagerie d'un logo à des consommateurs
saadé compte des conséquences qui se
font tout à fait non donc c'est là
qu'intervient un travail marketing de se
dire mais comment est-ce qu'on peut
suffisamment s'éloigner de cette
identité qui ne nous convient plus pour
en trouver une qui soit proche de nos
valeurs actuelles sans complètement se
dissocier et sortir finalement de
l'espace qu'on occupait dans la mémoire
des consommateurs donc ça va vraiment
être un jeu d'équilibriste pour se
retrouver une identité mais qui ne soit
pas trop loin non plus de ce que l'on a
réussi à construire dans l'esprit des
consommateurs c'est un travail qui est
qui est loin d'être évident et qui a des
conséquences économiques et financières
extrêmement lourde ces démarches ont
beaucoup fait réagir sur les réseaux
sociaux à tel point que certains disent
dans ces cas là il faudrait faire cette
démarche pour toutes les marques
associées une femme at-elle marque ou un
mexicain une marque bien connue de de
gâteaux
est-ce que là aussi il faut il faut
avancer selon vous alors je pense qu'on
n'aura pas le choix d'avancer les mêmes
certaines équipes de football américain
le même souci certaines autres marques
quand on voit un amérindien et le logo
je pense qu'en fait la question ne se
pose même pas s'il faut bouger
je pense qu'on n'aura pas le choix
aujourd'hui avec la sphère de georges
floyd on va dépasser 1,1 point je pense
de non retour et toutes les marques
effectivement peuvent utiliser ce type
d' emma d'imagerie devront à court ou au
plus tard moyen terme changer les choses
encore une fois dans l'idéal pour une
stratégie marketing pertinente
ça serait de pouvoir être proactif sur
ces sujets-là éviter d'attendre qu'on
soit un point d'exaspération au niveau
sociétal pour procéder à ces changements
une marque a aussi un rôle à jouer dans
la société dans laquelle on vit
alors vous parlez de stratégie marketing
est ce que ça va révolutionner aussi
toutes ces stratégies marketing à
l'avenir on va on va penser à tout ce
que ça peu arte avant d'afficher une
image vous d'associer une image à un
produit selon vous alors complètement et
il faut faire attention parce que une
identité de marque efficace et une
identité qui va se différencier qui va
pouvoir être original et pour pouvoir
être original
il faut se méfier de ne pas toujours
être trop dans la bien pensante
encore une fois je pense qu'il ya des
limites qui sont très claires
aujourd'hui utilisé des personnes de
couleur qui font référence à un passé
dont 11 de plus mais ce n'est plus à
l'ordre du jour mais ce n'est pas pour
cela qu'il va lui falloir créer
uniquement des marques lisse sans
identité qui ne vont heurter personne
par contre il ya des sujets sur lesquels
on ne peut plus heurter déranger ou même
chatouiller en terme d'image mais le
discours de marc et c'est ce à quoi il
faut être vigilant donc toujours entité
originales toujours se différencier mais
par contre bien entendre ce que la
société ne veut plus entendre et le type
de société d'imagerie que les
consommateurs et les consommatrices ne
veulent plus voir
et comment comment ça se passe
concrètement quand une marque peut
adopter une image et l'associer à son
produit est ce qu'elle fait d une
prospective est ce qu elle
ce monde des consommateurs avant alors
complètement parce que encore une fois
cet été des des projets qui qui utilise
d'énormes budgets d'un point de vue
financier c'est des investissements
extrêmement lourd
donc on fait ce qu'on appelle des focus
groups en amont ont fait énormément le
test avec du public public cible coeur
de cible du public non cibles mais
l'idée c'est d'arriver sur le marché
avec quelque chose qui va être efficace
et qui va séduire en aucun cas on peut
dépenser des millions d'euros ou des
millions de dollars on ne sachant pas où
on va
donc on teste on fait des essais des
erreurs on modifie et encore une fois la
magie de cette recette là se trouver
quelque chose qui peut convenir au plus
grand nombre sans toutefois se fondre
dans la masse et être différenciées
c'est ce juste équilibre qu'il faut
trouver dernière question quelles ont
été les conséquences économiques pour
cette marque de riz que l'on voit à
l'écran est ce que le boycott est réel
et les conséquences financières
dommageable pour la marque
alors pour l'instant au niveau des
chiffres on n'a pas à proprement parler
de véritable boycott jusqu'à présent
encore en 2017 y avait une pétition qui
circulait pour que uncle ben's change
son logo
aujourd'hui je n'ai pas de données
précises sur les conséquences
financières
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il faut
qu'ils aillent ça va être tout le tout
le défi c'est qu'il faut qu'ils aillent
vite et qu'il fasse bien donc s'ils
réagissent rapidement s'ils montraient
qu'ils comprennent et que d'eux mêmes
ils vont changer leur façon de faire et
leur façon de se présenter il pourrait
éviter la casse au niveau financier
encore une fois il faut une marque qui
ce qui explique qu'ils aient transparent
qui montre qu'elle comprend et qui
réagit rapidement aura des impacts
financiers vraiment minoré par rapport à
une marque qui ne fait semblant de ne
pas entendre ce que c'est quand le
consommateur lui disent merci beaucoup
et les des lignes d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france